we are going to take a tour today
through three elements of the current
american right wing and we're going to
go through them from the top down and
it's going to be about this movement
called trumpism we it starts with trump
then it goes to other elected officials
who are just as wacky or wackier and
then it goes to the people that follow
them and we're going to be able to see
all of this through a rally in georgia
that donald trump held over the weekend
we're going to look at what trump said
we're going to look at what other
republicans said and we'll look at what
rally-goers said so we're going to start
here first with donald trump i want to
remind you
very small crowd
this was the smallest trump rally crowd
in georgia in six years
barely 5 000 people trump always says
there's 50 000 people here he said at a
recent rally there were 87 000 people
there there weren't those are just lies
but it is true that trump used to get 10
to 20 000 people at these rallies barely
5 000 people entire sections with very
very empty seats so understand that
context let's jump right into the first
clip where donald trump seems to be very
clearly saying i'm running i'm running
in 2024 but he also says he's already
won twice i ran twice
i won twice
and i did much better the second time
and now
we just may have to do it again
imagine being this excited this excited
that the guy who lost your party
everything
he lost the white house after one term
he oversaw republicans losing the senate
he oversaw republicans losing the house
they lost everything under trump and
they want more it's like a comedy show
at this time
except it's not
then
this is a classic trump unintelligible
rant it's something about gas prices
but trump is visibly confused he
glitches i can't make heads or tails out
of what he's saying because energy is so
expensive today a gallon you take a look
at your forget about it the pump you
take a look at a barrel now it'll be two
dollars it could be people are saying
it's going to go up to
if think of this people are saying
oh man a barrel might go all the way up
to three bucks that that would be the
best deal on a barrel i could imagine
per barrel this is going over a hundred
dollars it's going over 150 it's going
up to 200 and 250 dollars so we're
making these countries by the way they
cut to a vietnam veteran who seems as
confused as anybody in the crowd look at
the look on this guy's face uh okay so
uh it does not appear that any of what
trump is saying is is going to happen um
oil went up it got to about 125 it came
back down it may go up a little bit
again but
what trump is saying is is just doesn't
make any sense whatsoever trump also
back to saying putin is smart he's going
he's he's going back to putin as smart
[Applause]
but they asked me is putin smart yes
putin was smart and i actually thought
he was going to be negotiating i said
that's a hell of a way to negotiate put
200 000 soldiers
on the border it should have never
happened
certain things and that thing would have
ended but they didn't have the common
sense they didn't know what to do we
wouldn't have even had to give him i
think he got
he made a big mistake i think he made a
big mistake all right so it's it's
completely unintelligible what sort of
point donald trump is trying to make
there then trump told one of these sir
stories where he says they they said sir
but this story is the opposite of
relatable trump says because of the
supply chain issues tiffany is out of
rings which the crowd really can relate
with
who the hell ever heard of this stuff
you go to the stores and the sorcerer
the cupboards are empty
you go into tiffany and where is your
ego sir we think we can have it in the
next uh seven to eight months oh that's
wonderful
the good news is you don't buy anything
you save a lot of money okay yeah and of
course trump's uh trump's crowd that's a
common problem they're trying to buy
rings at tiffany and they're on back
order that's a really really common
problem trump did address these
confirmation hearings of judge katanji
brown jackson and this is beyond parody
trump says that jackson
was disrespectful
to the republican senators if you can
imagine that but judge jackson
was unbelievably disrespectful to
republican senators what that in many
cases were really nicely
asking questions
she had total disdain and even hatred
for them and
i understand that she's very proud of
the fact that she never once voted
to support president trump on anything
she always
yes they were very nicely asking
questions like are babies racist
are you soft on
people
convicted for a child molestation or for
explicit images of children can you
define a woman
and other similarly respectful questions
i mean quite literally you could just
you hear trump and then you go okay the
opposite of that that must be what is
true
also this is a clip that reminds us how
desensitized we are
to the absurdity of what trump now says
where um he can now
essentially say
other governors haven't helped me with
the coup
and it doesn't even really make
headlines anymore
but he had no
chance
at the time in his opinion against
stacey abrams he was going to beat him
and then he asked me to get involved and
i had two rallies like this 52 000
people at each at the airport
i said brian you're going to win
and he said i don't think so sir
i said you're gonna win brian i don't
think so sir i don't think i can beat
her
i said brian look at this crowd but
they're here for you and you know what
it's true they weren't here for him they
were for me
and he ended up winning
twice
okay he ended up winning and then when
we needed help
he wasn't there for
this country and it was for the country
he wasn't there
but the bad news is
he wasn't there to help me with the coup
that's an insane thing for a former
president to say and we are so
desensitized to it that that didn't even
make headlines two more quick clips here
of course trump is the perfect victim he
is the one treated the most unfairly
everybody's so mean to trump
now
no president has ever suffered like i've
suffered at the hands of these animals
people say to me how the hell did you do
it and i can't even give him an answer i
don't know
i think i did it
because i love you and because we have a
job to do nobody has ever been treated
this unfairly and then last clip
it is march almost april of 2022
hillary clinton has not been a candidate
for almost six years
and they're chanting locker up
i'm suing for millions of dollars in
damages against crooked hillary clinton
james comey andrew mccabe
the two lovers who remember the lovers
peter strzok and lisa fay
and they're going around suing everybody
they use the fbi's web that was not a
good idea
they used the fbi servers
their for law order their for due
process and yet they say lock someone up
who hasn't even been charged with a
crime
this is a very sick group of people but
remember trump's only part of it after
the break we'll look at his acolytes who
spoke at the rally and then we'll look
at the rally goers which are i would
argue just as bad and potentially even
more dangerous so we'll take a quick
break we'll have all of these clips on
our instagram at david pakman show and
we'll be right back
one of our sponsors is splendid spoon
now if you're like me i love planning my
meals out for the week but sometimes i
just run out of time to plan them for
every single day and splendid spoon
makes that whole process a lot easier
they deliver fresh delicious plant-based
meals right to your door ready to eat no
cooking no cleaning dishes saves you a
lot of time you can choose from over 50
hot and cold meal options there's
smoothies grain and noodle bowl soups
i'm a big soup guy many of you know that
i also really liked the vegan meatballs
with marinara noodles delicious
both eye and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good
for helping the environment the list
goes on i'm not vegan you all know that
i think but splendid spoon is really
great to just help me maximize the
proportion of plants in my diet splendid
spoon takes all of the work out of tasty
healthy plant-based meals and you'll
save 35 dollars when you go to
splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below